quand michel mr aujourd'hui seuls maires
il arpentait les soirées parisiennes
c'est un bellâtre qui faisait de
l'audiovisuel dans les années 2000 jean
michel maire avait deux passions dans la
vie le sexe et le frisbee
malheureusement ces paroles n'ont jamais
acheté de frisbee
donc il a dû se rabattre sur sa deuxième
passion jean michel mr a commis l'erreur
de ne pas venir hier sur son lieu de
travail
car oui messieurs dames et vous qui nous
regardent et ici est un lieu de travail
même si il ya des glandeurs autour de la
table je vous demande de faire entrer
l'accusé fait leur entrée bordel
non michel mr bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là t'as plaisir hier vous deviez
être là également
vous deviez être là également il paraît
pareil commencé avec de l'insolence jean
michel maire hier on essaie de vous
joindre maintes et maintes fois facebook
twitter mais l'est-elle b bop tout ce
qui était en notre pouvoir
nous l'avons fait pour vous joindre
malheureusement aucune nouvelle news
nicht wir ski jean michel maire la
dernière photo
oui et tu de vous c'est cette photo vous
accompagner de lapine
mais aussi
jean-michel aujourd'hui je vous le
demande
où étiez-vous hier entre le début de
l'émission 18h45 et la fin de l'émission
2h30 du matin et les vaisseaux de plus
en plus longues non monsieur le maire de
boules demande sans détour et dites nous
la vérité et français vous regarde et
les français vous aime encore papa je
vous remercie de vous être inquiété
peut-être trop parce que quand j'ai
enfin rallumer hambourg table en fin de
journée j'avais 250 appels dont un appel
de ma mère presque en larmes
d'inquiétude savoir ce que je faisais et
malheureux mère commander ce qu'elle a
vu bah oui je sais les lapines qui en
voulaient à leur fils mais
malheureusement alors malheureusement la
vérité est très décevante vous attendait
peut-être des scoops mais j'avais
profité du beau temps
pensant que je ne faisais pas l'émission
une erreur regrettable pour faire des
courses dans paris voilà j'ai arpenté
les rues et j'ai fait
des courses dans paris vous avez de quoi
vous allez me dire que vous aviez acheté
de la salade pour nourrir vos lapins
jean michel maire à la salade des
carottes son lapin elle et la pincée
d'humour s'il vous plaît alors tout cas
en ce moment
si j'étais vous je me ferais tout petit
ami et la première veste à manches
courtes d'ailleurs c'est la seule baisse
regardez ma rivale saluer faut pas plat
taxi avec touch est pas le faire alors
mais juste et je savais vous n'alliez
pas me croire
alors c'est la vérité vraie je faisais
des courses est d'ailleurs quelqu'un m'a
envoyé sur mon facebook une vidéo qu'il
a prise à mon insu prouvant que je
faisais des courses et comme j'ai eu
l'envié je les donne la production pour
qui vous montre la preuve que j'avais
cette vidéo wii de renvoyer la peau la
vidéo d'hier exactement d'après midi
juste avant l'émission
envoyez là on va voir si la régie vous
écoute
effectivement et on doit vous étiez au
casino est complètement d'accord
je crois qu'il est honnête gilles verdez
moi aussi j'ai une vidéo
et cet homme ment parce que la vidéo que
nous avons vu est tronqué c'est une
copie c'est une fausse vidéo
moi j'ai communiquer à vos services les
vraies images il voulait donc j'ai les
images vous avez les images mais
services sont les ouates mes services
vos services en les images alors si les
services pourrait faire partir l'image
assez rapidement vous avez la mairie
écoutez
je crois qu'on est tous en mesure de le
dire c'est une enquête rondement menée
bravo mois sur m verdez inspecteurs vers
des si on peut pas être sur le terrain
faut le dire tout de suite
et donc voilà jean-michel je préfère la
vérité vous avez avoué j'ai avoué à
moitié ça c'est franchement c'est pour
la blague 13 manger bull portal mes
mains sur un accident reste est cassé
l'épaule je suis allé en province vers 3
dans les vignes où mon téléphone ne
passait pas donc j'ai part si vous
appelle à rouler der garde et ses
enfants parce qu'elle est et le bauhaus
pitié oui oui bien sûr oui c'était juste
la l'épaule cassée à l'épaule café
j'aurais su j'aurais couru jusqu'à paris
pour revenir évidemment l'épaule cassée
très bons albums de tintin maya